これを0
アズ写像
公園とらー
おいおぉお知らせていただきます
うぇい
おじゃーんっ
2分
[音楽]
+違うポイント
お願いしまーす心の整理4キロ太りました
瀬際のではじめの一言が欲しいです
ギター頑張れと言ってほしい
ビネガー所命令
このへ
[拍手]
あっはーん tan ん
うん
[音楽]
母国困ってることがあります今年受験生なのですが本当に困ってます
どうやったら二学期で開けますかゆうさんで習ってください
このへ
[拍手]
はあああんん
[音楽]
ん
iko 矜持が経ってません玉置さんとを応援してください
[音楽]
ジャイどうぞ a
このへ
[拍手]
はぁ派
[音楽]
ユンドン
mood ん
うん
[音楽]
ブーブー巴
狛江
[拍手]
んん
うん
乳輪を小さくしたいんで応援よろしくお願いします
ただ無理で狛江
[拍手]
えっん
うぜ
ん
[音楽]
ゆんん
うん
[音楽]
ブーバより女子9実際の誕生日
おめーぞ2カ月遅れてごめんなさい
狛江
[拍手]
歩兵ん
うちの
うん
voodoo ん
ん
うん
入山結局を受けて業務でを失うことがほぼ決まっています
11月11時手術があるのですが bb 弾でとても怖くて不安です
いつも応援している方に逆に応援していただけたら雪がモテると思いましてコメントさ
せていただきました
速さんって呼んでもらえたら嬉しいですみなさーん
狛江
あったのって
おやじさん
頑張ってください
女王
終わっていますよねーこれなさーい
巴
[拍手]
はぁんっ
うん
ん
[音楽]
うざん
うん
[音楽]
友達と好きな人が変わりました気成尾前
[拍手]
ん
うん
ブーバーちっニェッ逃げません
[音楽]
構え
[拍手]
ん
うぜ
うづん
うん
今日は良いやと言います僕はクラシックバレエを勉強し自動一のバレエ学校に留学中の
高校2年生です
現在留学1か月目バレエの経験もまだ全然少なくて今まで出たとこ勝負で生きてきたの
で
特に語学は何も勉強せずに海外で起きてしまって全く人とコミュニケーションが取れて
いません
それはいいんです
けど特に困っているのが自分や0
いることが分からなかったり自分と伝えたいことを先生ヒロが答えられなかったりする
ことが多くあたってすごく困ってます
もちろん現地で語学の塾に通ったにオンラインなどで勉強をしていますがあまり出走が
ないのですながー
お前
[拍手]
re 本を
まあ
うん
[音楽]
懸命のページするまでに便利がなんだかなって家が出るように思うしてください
女性を萌え
[拍手]
は
[音楽]
ん
君の
ええええええええええええええええええ
うん
ベッドでな違いがわからないです助けてください一緒でお前
mood ん
うん
たぶん僕合計なんですけどどうすればいいですかね
将来が心配ですうズレ狛江
[拍手]
[音楽]
4ん
ん
うん
k 行間18共感が出ておりました
思ったらー
このへ
はん
ん
うん
私はストレスで過敏性腸症候群になって嫌なあだ名を付けられて私に聞こえるように
いじめっ子が悪口を言ってきたり机終わるかけってきたり廊下でわざと横に広がって私
を通さないようにするかとまあそうみたいなことをしてきます
二辛くてもう学校に行きたくないですでも親が学校に行けというので渋々学校に行って
います
いじめっ子全員音とワープ潰してやりたいとでさぁ
それはちょっとできないのでいじめっ子にきちんと止めてと言える勇気がほしいです
応援してくれたら嬉しいです負けるなー
dollar
東映
ブーブーの
ん
[音楽]
うん
ブーブー10 a
[音楽]
bl